hello welcome to section 3
of ee104 this is about predictors
so one of the primary tasks in machine
learning
is data fitting we have
a variable y and a variable x and
we think they're related by some
function
say y say y is equal to f of x
we think y is approximately equal to f
of x
here we think about x as an independent
variable
and y is the outcome or
the response we might call it the target
or the label or the dependent variable
very often we have y is in our m and x
is in our
d so these are both vectors
very often m is one and so the outcome
is a scalar
and we say well the target is related to
the independent variable approximately
by y is f of x
and we're going to be told x and we'd
like to be able to predict y
and we don't know what this function f
is
and of course there may not be such a
function f it may just be that y
and x are a bunch of unrelated data or
they're related by some other variable
that we don't know
or for you put an x in one time you'll
get a y
you put an x in a different time you'll
get a different y
and there's a lot of noise
there's a probabilistic relationship
between y and x rather than a
purely deterministic one usually these
x's these variables x
usually these variables x are vectors of
features
that is they are descriptors of
the underlying data rather than the
underlying data itself
so for example if we have documents for
each document we might make a histogram
of the word counts and count the numbers
of all of the different words and that
would be
x that vector of the of the word counts
if we had patient data then x might be
patient attributes test robot results
systems
let's start again
very often x is a vector of features
rather than the raw underlying data
so for example if we had a document
then the corresponding x might be a
account of all of the different words in
the document the word count histogram
if we had patient data then x might be
a list of different patient attributes a
list of test results
perhaps a list of symptoms
if our data consists of customers then
for each customer will have an x
which would be the purchase history
history of that customer
we have a general framework
to construct features from
the raw input data so the raw
input data might be it might be a vector
itself
it might be a word or a document it
might be an image it might be video
it might be audio
or it could be a list of such attributes
could consist of multiple attributes
we're going to call
that input data u and we're going to
map it under a function phi to construct
x which we will call the corresponding
feature vector
this function phi has a name it's called
the embedding or the feature
function or the feature mapping
and sometimes phi is very simple and
sometimes it's
extremely complicated um
and from we will
take a particular property
we will make sure that since phi is
going to be a vector we'll make sure
that the first component of
phi is always
one and so that we would note by
x sub 1 or fire view subscript 1.
it's the constant feature
which will explain the reason for that
in just
a second
similarly we embed or
reconstruct features for
the output data v and we will call those
y
and we will have y is equal to psi of v
so our data comes in pairs
uis and vis the ith data element
is a pair ui vi we map those
to a pair x i y i
and we have in data points x1 to xn
and y1 to yn and once we've embedded
them once we've constructed
features then
we no longer need to look directly at u
and v instead we can focus our attention
on x and y so we will have n
d dimensional vectors x1 through xn
and n m dimensional
vectors y1 through yn y 1 to yn
and so we'll refer to the pair x i wire
as the ith
data pair or observation
particularly evocative term is to refer
to as the i
example from which we wish to learn
and collectively we recall the entire
set of x's and y's
a data set
um we're also so that's our
fundamental data that we're going to use
in order to construct
some fitted
model for the relationship between x and
y
we also might have prior knowledge about
what f
might look like for example if f is a
a function we might say f is
smooth or continuous which means that
if x and x tell there are two vectors
that are close to each other then f of x
and
f of x tilde should also be close to
each other
another thing we might know prior
knowledge about f is that we might know
that y
is always non-negative and so we would
like to
ensure that property of
f poles in our model we're going to
learn from x's and y's and we're going
to see
a whole bunch of y values and no matter
what
y values we we see we would like to
ensure that
the model that our learning algorithm
produces
has the property that f of any x is
always non-negative
and there are many other such prior
knowledge
so and there are many other examples of
prior knowledge that one might have
so the thing we're going to construct is
called a predictor
it's a model that takes an x
and gives you a prediction for what y
would be at that
x we denote that by g
it's a function that takes vectors in rd
x's and gives us vectors in our m
y's
for the feature vector x the prediction
we will denote by y hat y hat is g of x
and the predictor g is chosen on
the basis of two things the the data
that we've seen and the prior knowledge
that we have
and that means that we can in terms of
the raw data
construct a prediction using a new
raw data record so if you give me
a new u that i've never seen before i
can
map it under phi to embed it and give me
an
x construct a feature vector
corresponding to that u
then i can take that x and feed it into
my predictor
to construct g of x and that's an
estimate
for y a prediction for y and then i can
unembed that by applying the inverse
of the feature map psi
to that y hat to give me an estimate of
v which we'll call v-hat
[Music]
and that means that i can test my the
performance of my predictor
in the original in terms of the original
data
rather than in terms of my x's and y's
and sometimes psi is not invertible and
then there's a slight
variation of this formula that we will
come to
of course you can also evaluate how well
does this predictor do on the data
and we can take a data pair the ice data
pair is x
i y i your feed x i into g
we'll get a y hat we'll call y hat i
and uh we would like y hat i to be close
to y
i and that means that the predictor does
well on the data
that's a very reasonable thing to
require of the predictor
of course our real goal is not to have
the
predictor do well on the data but to
have
predicted the predictor do well on
potential data that we've not yet seen
when
somebody gives us some new x
or some new u they could quite
reasonably ask well what did you learn
from all that earlier data
that we gave you the answer should be
well
from all that data i learned that these
kinds of x's give rise to
these kinds of y's and let me predict a
specific y
that would be generated by the x that
you just gave me
now when we're working with predictors
we typically don't just say well here's
the predictor
we typically have a parametrized form
for the predictor so the predictor
is a function of two things it's a
function of x and it's a function
of some parameters theta
so we would have y hat is g of x
and theta sometimes we write this as a
subscript so we'll write the
y hat is g subscript theta of x and that
just makes it easy to
refer to g g theta as a function which
takes an x
and gives us a y and what this does for
us is it
specifies a form a structure
allowed predictors or predictors that we
like
and we're only going to pick predictors
that correspond to a particular theta
and our job becomes instead of choosing
an arbitrary function
that maps x to y choose
a theta and then evaluate g of x theta
so cedar is uh a parameter uh
it's it's usually a vector it uh
uh it's a parameter for the prediction
model
um often theta is in some euclidean
space
uh here we've written our p sometimes
it's a matrix
we'll see that um and sometimes it's a
it's a list of
there's more than one parameter more
than one parameter vector more than one
parameter matrix
um choosing a particular
theater that's called tuning
or training or fitting the model
and a learning algorithm is a recipe for
choosing cedar given
data so for example
we might have a linear regression model
that says
that y hat is theta 1
x 1 plus theta 2 x 2 all the way up to
theta d
times x d y hat is this linear
combination of the thetas
or equivalently a linear combination of
the x's
and uh
our job is to pick the thetas so that uh
this is a good predictor we've already
seen in previous classes on linear
algebra that you can fit such a linear
regression model
using least squares and that's picking
theta to minimize the mean square error
of course there are lots of other
methods for picking for doing linear
regression for picking the thetas
even in a linear regression model and we
will talk about some of those in this
class
i want to talk about a special class of
predictors called nearest neighbor
predictors
they work as follows we're given a data
set
x1 to xn y1 through yn
and the predictor says the following
you've got some new x and you'd like to
predict a corresponding y-hat
the way you do it is out of all of the
data that you got
you find the the x i that is the nearest
to x
and then your prediction for the
corresponding y
is simply y i and that you define
to be g of x
at that x
and so this is extremely intuitive
if you've got some new piece of data and
you want to make a prediction about what
y is at that data point
with that x well you know why not look
for the closest
example that matches it and say well
uh that's probably
the this is the closest example we've
got so let's predict
that the y we get is the why we got in
that previous example
um it
really is of course a parametrized
predictor here the parameter is a bit
interesting because the parameter is the
full
data set you can think about theta as x1
through x
n and y1 2y and the entire data set
and we don't have to choose the
parameter the parameter
is given to us with the data it is the
data
so training is easy there isn't any
training there's no computation to be
done
all you have to do is keep track of all
the data we've seen and whenever we get
a new query point a new x
we just look for the closest x in the
data set and get returned the
corresponding y
this means that g is going to be a
piecewise constant
function of x because when x is closer
to x
i than all the other x's well g of x is
just y i
we can see that on this plot right here
let me see if i can highlight some
points on this
so these are data points
and the orange line
which i will highlight here in black
this wiggles about here
is the predictor and it tells us
that for example if we receive
a a value
of x of 0.2
then we should predict the corresponding
value
y of 0.47
and so even though we've only got data
points at specific points we've
fitted a curve not a curve really a
piecewise constant for
a piecewise constant function through
those points
something to observe is that that the
function
is has discontinuities
let's look at some of those
discontinuities
so here's one here's another
here's another and these discontinuities
are exactly halfway between two adjacent
data points
so as we vary x when we're here
we are our closest data point is this
red point here
and then as we increase x we suddenly
switch to the closest data point being
this
data point x right here and as a result
we
we switch our prediction also from
predicting the y
corresponding to this data point to
predicting the y corresponding to this
data point
you can do this in uh more than one
dimension it doesn't have to be
a a one dimensional x here one can do
this when x is d
dimensional as well here's a two
dimensional case
uh the two dimensional case here we have
uh
uh data points which have uh
which are right here i'll highlight
these blue points
and
and now associated with each data point
it shows you
associated with each x there is a
region so for example for this data
point right here
there's a region which is this region
right here
which is a polyhedron it's got straight
boundaries
and this is the set of data points for
which the correspond this is the set of
x's
for which the corresponding closest data
point
is this one
if i'm here my closest data point
is this one you know if i move
across this boundary suddenly i switch
to
the case where my closest data point
becomes that one over there
so each data point has a corresponding
region
and those regions are called the voronoi
regions associated with the data
so the function the predictor is
piecewise constant
it's constant on voronoi regions and
here's a three-dimensional plot of it
this is x1 this is x2
and this is the prediction y or y-hat
and so here we have
again we have data points here
and then this is the function values
according on each data point so right
here on this
foreign region right here
that vorano region right there that's
the voronoi region corresponding to this
data point
the value at that data point is y is one
y i is minus one i'm sorry
and so if we are given a new x
which is anywhere in that region then we
will predict that y
hat is also minus one
so now we've seen the nearest neighbor
predictor
we can extend that idea and talk about
the k nearest neighbor predictor
so the idea here is that you pick a
number k an integer
and then you say well you give me an x
and instead of just looking at the
nearest neighbor to x
i'm going to look at the k nearest
neighbors
x i 1 through x i k
amongst the given data and what we're
going to predict
is we're going to predict y hat to
as follows we're going to take those k
nearest neighbors
the nearest x i's each one of them has a
corresponding y
i and so we've got k corresponding y i's
and we're going to construct the average
of those k y i's and that's going to be
y hat
so this is a a generalization of the
nearest neighbor predictor
um and uh
it's certainly very useful it's very
well used it
uh you might see that uh for example
it makes you less sensitive to uh
noise in the data if the data is very
variable
then the k nearest neighbor predictor is
going to perform some averaging
it's going to smooth out the data it's
going to remove some of the noise
and there are many ways you might extend
this idea you might use a weighted
average
to form y hat or you might pre-process
the data you might say well i'm only
going to look at
uh the data instead of looking at it as
a
collection of data points i'm just going
to look at it as a collection of
clustered
data points the collection of clusters
of data points
and then instead of picking the nearest
neighbor i might pick the nearest
cluster
there's a bunch of different things you
could do
here's how you compute the k nearest
neighbor predictor this is
julia so we have a function
it takes an x a y
a little x and a k
so here this matrix x
it is uh an n by d
matrix the uh i th row
of that is the i x
point it's x
variable corresponding to the ith data
record
uh y here is
uh also
an n by m matrix
it's uh uh the corresponding targets
the ice rho of y is the target variable
corresponding to the i throw of x
here little x is um
the query point we're given a new
x at which we want to predict a y that's
little x and k here is the k in nearest
neighbors it's how many neighbors we're
going to consider
uh so this first line of the code here
just gives us
the in the number of data points it
looks just that the number
that returns the number of rows of the
matrix x
here we look at
each row and subtract
it from the query point look at the sum
of the squares
of uh the entries of that vector
and where we make a list of all the sums
of the squares
for each of the different data points
for eyes one to n
and that's in dists square that's a list
of all of those different distances the
i
element of that list is the distance
from x i to x
and then this function sort perm gives
us the indexes
the indices that point to
the sorted uh
entries of this square so
the first entry of nearest neighbor
idx's
is an integer and if we look at the
um uh
so so if the nearest neighbor index is
uh
the if if the first entry of nearest
neighbor indexes is seven
then dist square seven will be the
smallest
entry in disc square and similarly
the second entry in nearest neighbor
indexes
points to the second smallest entry in
this
square so if we look at the first k
by picking out the first k entries
returned by sort perm
that gives us k numbers
that point to the corresponding
closest data records to x
and then what we do is we construct the
corresponding take the corresponding y's
and we take their average
and we return that as y hat
this is of course if you were to write
this in python or matlab
uh it would look very similar the nice
thing about
this code is that really it looks very
much like the mathematics that
one might write to describe
this algorithm and that's a
nice feature that is worth aiming at
throughout this class is that if you've
got a short piece of mathematics that
describes
something you're trying to code then the
code should kind of correspond
line by line to the mathematics and
that way it's easy to debug and uh
easy to read
so this is the the case where ks2 on the
same data that we had
before and now this is interesting
in that regions uh let me mark a region
so for example this region right here
regions are still have polyhedral still
have straight line boundaries they're
still polyhedra
but they now rather than corresponding
to a single data point they correspond
to k data points in this case k is 2.
so every point
in this region right here
its two closest
data points are this one
and this one
and you can see that if i'm in this
region and i cross
over into this region then i'm going to
switch from having
this one and this one
as my closest data points to having
instead
this one and this one that's my closest
to data points
so now regions are associated with pairs
of data points
there are more regions because there are
more pace of data points than there are
individual data points
although not every pair of data points
has a non-empty region
and we can plot the corresponding k
nearest neighbors estimate here it is on
the right hand side
there are more regions but also the the
function itself is somewhat flatter has
less variability
and that's something we expect because
the
uh okay nearest neighbors
a predictor does averaging
and so instead it's going to smooth out
the function
it's still of course piecewise constant
now instead we can do is another variant
of the k nearest neighbors this is the
soft
nearest neighbor predictor and what we
do here is we take a
weighted average of the measured y
but the weights that we use aren't fixed
they depend
on x and so here's a very common choice
of weights
right here these weights are interesting
one thing you might notice is that
if i sum those up from eyes 1 up to n
then w i is equal the sum over i of w
i is equal to 1. let's write that down
perhaps using that
so
another thing to notice is that there's
a parameter here the parameter is
row now it's it's a it has the
dimensions or the scaling like a length
so in particular
if you look here in the numerator i've
got the norm
of x minus x i squared divided by rho
squared
so when rho is very small
well one over rho squared is very large
and so e to the minus something
divided by rho squared is going to be
extremely small unless we're unless
there's something in the numerator
unless the x minus x i
norm squared is also very small unless
it's of the similar size
to to rho squared and so what that means
is that
when rho is very small this quantity
is going to be 1 when x is close to x
i and 0
almost everywhere else
and that means that this weighted sum
that i'm going to get right here
is going to be the nearest
the value of y at the nearest
point x i the newest i
that at the nearest data point
um so this reverts to the nearest
neighborhood predictor when row is small
when row is large it becomes a little
different
let's look at what it becomes so i won't
go through this code
but this code is because it's very
similar to the previous code
um it uh just explicitly follows the
mathematics again
so here the here are the uh
the soft nearest neighbors predictor
uh this is the case where row is two on
the left here
and you can see it's really rather
smooth
when row is 1 it's becoming
a little bit more similar
to the uh
the nearest neighbor predictor
here we can see when rho is 0.5
over here we we can see something that's
really quite close
to the the nearest neighbors predictor
and uh on the newest neighbor predictors
here on the left and we can really see
that there's a correspondence between
those two
so this is a nice way of smoothing out
the
uh the nearest neighbor predictor and it
instead of us having a discontinuous
piecewise
constant function one has a smooth
function and we can make it
as smooth as we like
okay so let's turn now to another class
of predictors the linear predictor
here g has the form g of x theta is
theta transpose
multiplied by x so when m is one that
means y is a scalar
the parameter theta is a vector in our d
and theta transpose x just returns for
us a scalar
when m is greater than one theta here is
a matrix which is d
by m and so theta transpose times x is
going to return for us an
m dimensional vector same size as y
this is also called a linear regression
model
and y
hat which is uh
g of x is theta 1 times x 1 plus theta 2
times
x 2 all the way up to theta d times x d
which is a linear combination of the
theta i's with coefficients
x 1 through x d here
if m is 1 then theta i is just the ice
entry of theta if m is greater than 1
then theta i transpose is the ice
rho of theta and
so each of the theta i's has a
a dimension same as y
so we can interpret this um
[Music]
suppose y is scalar just for the
uh to make the explanation simple
you can of course extend all of these
ideas when y is a vector
well then the linear predictor has the
form y hat
which is g of x is theta 1 times x 1
plus theta 2 times x 2
all the way up to theta d times x d
and that means that we can interpret the
thetas very directly
so theta um
theta 3 is the amount that the
prediction
y hat increases when x3 increases by one
uh if you happen to be in the case where
your x3 is a boolean
so it only takes value zero or one
then theta 3 is going to tell you how
much y hat is affected
when x3 turns on or turns off
if theta 7 is 0 well that tells us
something also tells us that the
prediction
does not depend on x7
and in general theta is small as a
vector means that the prediction is
insensitive to changes in x and there's
a very little
nice little one line computation here
that
illustrates that
here we're looking at the absolute value
of the difference between g of x and g
of x tilde so we've got two different
x's and um
well g of x theta transpose x and
g of x told us theta transpose x tilde
and so gathering together
the excess we get that that's equal to
theta transpose x
minus x tilde and now we can use the
koshi schwarz inequality remember what
that is let me just write it down
it says that for two vectors say p and q
that the absolute value of p transpose q
is less than or equal to the the norm
of the vector p multiplied by the norm
of the vector q and
of course we know that p transpose q is
the norm of p
multiplied by the norm of q multiplied
by the cosine of the angle between p
and q and cosine is between -1 and 1.
that means that this quantity the
absolute value of this scalar product
is less than or equal to the norm of
theta times the norm of x minus
x tilde and so if theta
is very small so if the norm of theta is
small
then the difference between g of x and g
of x tilde
can't be very big because it's bounded
by that small quantity multiplied by the
norm of x minus x tilde
so by making c the small you make your
predictor
insensitive to the data
and that doesn't sound like a good idea
but as we will see in this class that
turns out to be an extremely important
idea that we will
revisit again and again
uh in many cases if the first feature is
constant we made x1 as one and that's a
choice
we get to choose how we are constructing
the features what are
maps phi and psi are and so we often
choose
x1 to be one the constant feature
and the reason we do that is that then
the
the linear predictor so g of x is theta
transpose x
which has this term at the beginning of
it theta 1
a constant term which doesn't depend on
x
plus a term that is
linear in x so it's linear plus constant
and theta 1 is called the offset or the
constant term some people call it the
bias
in the predictor it's the prediction
when all the features
except for the constant of course are
zero
some people would call that an affine
predictor a linear plus constant
predictor
if it was a linear predictor then when x
was zero we would have to have y
hat be also zero here zero is
somewhere down here is the origin
and we can see that our prediction
doesn't pass anywhere
near the origin
another very common predictor is
the polynomial predictor so here
what we're doing is we're taking an
appropriate embedding we're choosing
features
um and by choosing features in this way
we can get a non-linear function of u
even though we're using a linear
predictor based on x
what you do it is you say i'm going to
construct this
feature map phi to be a vector
so you give it a u say u is a scalar
and we're going to construct a vector
feature
in a feature map which returns 1
u u squared u cubed all the way up to
the d
minus 1 power of u
and people would call phi polynomial or
power embedding
and it's interesting it's taking a uh
a one dimensional uh independent
variable u
and making a bigger regression problem
it's embedding it
in a d-dimensional regretting
[Music]
regression problem and that means when
we construct the linear predictor
we're going to have y hat as theta
transpose x
but actually theta transpose x is
theta one plus theta two u plus theta
three u squared all the way up to theta
d
u d minus one
so it's a linear function of x but a
polynomial function of u
here's an example so i've got a bunch of
data points here
and fitting a quadratic
here
or a cubic
right there
ah there are other nonlinear predictors
uh here's one this is a tree based
predictor
and the idea is is that we have a
predictor which is represented
by a partially developed boolean
tree and
at each vertex
which is not a leaf
such as this one or this one
we have
a variable an index into one of the
components
of x and associated with that
index or that component is a
threshold and that's the threshold which
is the decision
part at that node in the tree so we
start off coming in
with x we say is x
second component x two less than or
equal to point eight
or is it greater than point eight if
it's greater than point eight we go down
here
and we return a prediction y hat is
point six
if it's less than 0.8 less than or equal
to 0.8 we go down here
and then we end up with another at
another
non-leaf node and that's associated with
another decision
and that decision is x is x one less
than or equal to point two or is x one
greater than point two
if x one is less than or equal to point
two then we go down here when we return
y hat is point two five
if x1 is greater than 0.2 then we go
down here
we determine y has 0.5
so the leaves are associated with the
values these are the leaves
and the non-leaf nodes are associated
with
conditions
and the predictor is a piecewise
constant function of x
and we could plot it as a piecewise
at least when the tree is small enough
here's a one-dimensional x here what's
the tree for this well we can work it
out
let me switch to a smaller
pen we go
x first decision we have a choice we can
there's not there's more than one way to
write any given
decision tree let's do let's look at
this
point right here first and we'll say
if x is less
than 0.2 then we're going to have
y hat is 0.25
here we've got another decision to make
and this one is going to be here and the
decision is
so here we x is greater than 0.2
and here where the decision is is x
less than 0.8 or is x greater
than 0.8 and if it's less than 0.8
then we're going to have y hat equal to
0.5
and if it's greater than 0.8 we're going
to have y hat
equal to 0.6 so there's our decision
tree
corresponding to this
predictor right here
and of course if we're in higher
dimensions then we're slicing up
the vector space corresponding to rd
into uh rectangular regions
and at each vertex at each normally
vertex of the tree
we're making another cut
now let's look at another class of
predictors these are the neural network
predictors
very important very powerful class of
extremely widely used
so what is a neural network a a neural
network this is a feed-forward neural
network which is perhaps the most common
type of neural network
there are others as well that we will
discuss but this is the most common kind
it's a composition of functions
so here i've got uh three functions g1
g2 and g3 and i take x
and i apply it to g1 and then i take the
result and apply
it to g2 and then take the result and
apply it to g3 and that gives me y-hat
and you can have any number of functions
here
here we've just got three for the sake
of example
now we write that using this notation
that the predictor g
is g3 composed with g2 composed with g1
and this symbol with a little circle
means function composition
these gi's are called layers of the
neural network and here we have three of
them
uh we can split up this function
composition into
three independent things first of all we
apply
x we take g1 and apply it
x and get z1 then we take g2
apply it to z1 and get z2 and then we
take
z2 we take g3 and apply it to z2 to get
our output y-hat and these
intermediate variables which we've
introduced here z1
and z2 are called
activations they're the outputs of
the ith layer
and to make it all consistent we might
make x here
g z zero and we might make
uh y hat here z
and that's a very reasonable
notational convenience that we'll make
use of
and and here it says here d0
and d3 and let me tell you what those
are because one of the things that's
going on here
is that each one of these z's can have a
different
dimension and we will have
z i is going to be in r
to the d i
and that way this notation d 0 is d
and d3 is m is simply expressing
our usual notational convention for the
dimension of x
being d and the dimension of y being m
you can visualize this is a nice graph
x comes in goes through g1 gives us
z1 goes through g2 gives us c2
goes through g3 gives us y-hat which we
might call a flow graph
for the data
these layer functions are have a
particular form
in neural networks here's what they look
like
they're the composition of a function
h with an affine function
so here theta i transpose
1 z i minus 1. what this parentheses
notation means
let me tell you what this means if i
write x
y z in parentheses that's exactly the
same
as writing a column vector x
y z with them stacked up on top of each
other
so when i write theta i transpose one
comma z
what i'm really saying is that i've got
some vector
theta i transpose
1 z
and that's of course i could expand that
as saying that's theta i 1
times 1 plus theta i
2 times z 1
plus all the way up to theta i
whatever the dimension is d plus one
times z d it's a linear combination of
the z
i's and of course i don't need to write
that one in there
because it's just one it's just the i1
so i take a linear combination of the
z's with a constant term
offset and then i apply a function h to
it
now remember that
the z's are vectors and the output can
also be vectors and that would mean
that theta i would be a matrix
in its dimension would be r
d i minus 1 plus 1 by d
i because its input
is a vector z
i minus 1 which has dimension r
d i minus 1 and its output is going to
have dimension
r d i
and this is the parameter associated
with the with layer i these are also
called the weights
now what i'm doing with that vector
which is
uh produced by this affine
function is i'm applying a scalar
function
h to it and that scalar function h is
called the activation function
and it acts element wise so it's applied
to each entry of the vector separately
um so what that means if the if i've got
a vector z
and it's equal to h of w
what that means is that z1 is
h of w1 z2
is h of w2 and so on it's really just a
shorthand
for applying the function separately to
each component
now the scalar function h is called the
activation function
uh there are many different activation
functions that are used in neural
networks
the most common one probably by far is
this one called the relu
let's uh take a look at that
so the relu is this thing
it's usually denoted by x parentheses
with a subscript plus
also written max of x comma 0.
what it is is we can just draw a little
graph of it here
this is
this is x and this is x
plus and it's graph
0 for negative x and just x
for positive x so if x is negative x
plus is just zero
if x is positive then
x plus is just x
let's call the value value is short for
rectified linear
unit another one that's quite common
is the sigmoid function e to the x
divided by 1 plus e to the x
and we will see a few others as well
that are commonly used for
activation functions um
so once one knows the matrices
theta one through theta m once one knows
the activation
functions one can construct the
functions
gi one can compose the functions gi
to have a predictor and that's a neural
network predictor
it's often drawn as a network
so here's a three layer neural network
remember what the functions are our
first function
g1 takes these two
variables x1 and x2
and constructs these four variables
so here the dimension here is
d is two
d one is four that's the dimension
of the variable at the first layer
it's the first activation
and we have
d2 is two and then we have m
is 1 which is just d3 is 1. and the
function
that maps us this way is g1 the function
that maps us this way is g2
and the function that maps us this way
is g3
but it's quite convenient to draw this
as
a network like this where we've expanded
out each of the variables
because then one can see several things
one can see
that for example the first component of
z1
depends on x1 and x2 as does the second
as does the third and as does the force
and the coefficients that enter into
this dependency
are the entries of the theaters so for
example
z one z two component one
is a linear combination of the z ones z
one one z one two z 1 3 z 1
4 plus a constant term
passed through the activation function
so it's h of
a linear combination of these plus a
constant term
the coefficient of z 1 1 is going to be
theta 2
2 1.
here we can also see that z14
is its coefficient is a is a the
activation function composed with
a linear combination of x1 and x2 plus a
constant
the coefficient in that linear
combination is theta 1 2
4. so these kinds of network diagrams
are
often drawn for neural networks very
often the theta eyes
are sparse matrices so they have lots
of zeros and that would mean that many
of these arrows
have zero coefficients associated with
them
in which case we typically wouldn't draw
arrows that have zero coefficients
um and so each of the vertices in this
graph is a component of an activation
and the edges are entries of the weight
matrices
now we would call them individual
weights or scalar parameters of the
neural network and so here we have three
layers
and we have specific dimensions of this
particular neural network
now by choosing the parameters what are
we going to choose we've got to choose
theta 1 and theta 2 and theta 3.
this is the dimension of theta 1 here
it's
3 by 4. this is the dimension of theta
two
it's five by two and this is a dimension
of c to three it's
three by one so there's quite a few
parameters that enter into
the thetas and of course the activation
function is a choice as well
that's not a parameter and we're going
to
pick the predictor from this family of
predictors
by choosing the thetas the h's are part
of the structural
form of the predictor by choosing these
thetas one can end up with a huge number
of different functions
which all look like crumpled pieces of
paper here's one for this particular
choice of theta
um you can see right here uh you can see
that it's uh a
piecewise linear function
but it's got complicated joins
in the function there's a complicated
join there and there
and
and one can end up with all sorts of
very strange functions
uh by picking the thetas and this is
simply with a three layer neural network
with
quite small number of variables uh
neural networks can have
millions of parameters and
and then it becomes impossible to
visualize or understand what those
parameters mean or how they work
so in summary a predictor is a function
it takes
x's which live in rd and gives us back
y's which live in rm
and it's meant to predict the outcome y
given a particular feature vector x
there are many different types of
predictors nearest neighbors
trees linear predictors neural networks
many others
and most of them are parametrized they
have the we'll write them g of theta of
x
g fixes the form and see there are
parameters
that we choose and we're going to choose
them so that we fit the data as well as
possible
and that's called training the predictor
and we're going to see later how
training is done